SEVENTEEN OKAY MEMBERS WE'RE
GONNA GO AHEAD AND BRING THE
COMMITTEE. TO ORDER.
WE WILL BEGIN BY ESTABLISHING A
QUORUM.
GOT A CALL.
SEARCH I PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
GRAY.
HERE.
BIGELOW PRESENT.
AG WE ARE CURRY.
I GOT CARRIED PRESENT
[inaudible]
BERMAN.
BONSER HERE BRO [inaudible]
JULIE [inaudible]
COOPER [inaudible]
DAILY [inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
GARCIA [inaudible]
GIBSON.
JOHN SAWYER PUT HIS OWN
[inaudible]
LACKEY [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
METHODS [inaudible]
MELINDA [inaudible]
PERK SILVER [inaudible]
RE THIS [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SOLACE [inaudible]
YEAH.
OKAY WE HAVE A QUORUM ESTABLISH
FOR WAITING ON OUR AUTHOR.
AND MEMBERS THANK YOU.
FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION TODAY'S
HEARING -- WE CALLED A SPECIAL
HEARING HERE SP FOUR SIXTY NINE
AS MANY OF YOUR WHERE WE'VE HAD --
SOME PUBLIC OUTCRY AND CONCERN
OVER THE ISSUES -- AT SANTA
ANITA -- THE HORSE RACING BOARD --
IS THE SUBJECT OF THIS
LEGISLATION SO WE WANTED.
TO MOVE THIS LEGISLATION AT THE
REQUEST OF OUR SENATE SENATE
LEADERSHIP IN OUR GOVERNOR --
DOWN GOVERNOR'S DESK AND THAT
WAS THE NEED FOR A SPECIAL
HEARING TODAY I APPRECIATE YOUR
ATTENDANCE WHILE WE WAIT FOR THE
AUTHOR WOULD MIGHT ALSO --
WELCOME OUR NEW COMMITTEE
SECRETARY RUBIN COREY FOR THOSE
OF YOU WHO HAVE NOT GOT A CHANCE --
TO GET TO KNOW ROBERT YOU SHOULD.
COME UP AND SAY HELLO
[inaudible]
YEAH WE WE GET IT RIGHT
YOU WANT.
WELL I WAS THINKING ABOUT IT.
YEAH HIGH PROFILE -- SO.
HE MIGHT HAVE.
THEY MIGHT.
GET A SEVEN FOR ALL -- HE'S
BRUTAL SIT THERE [inaudible]
ROB [inaudible]
YEAH.
THE YOUNGEST MEMBER.
THAT'S EVIDENCE.
IS ALMOST HERE
.
SHOULD BE A
THE
YOU HAVE THE
RIGHT.
WELCOME SENATOR.
WE HAVE ESTABLISHED A QUORUM AND
WE'RE PREPARED -- TO GET YOUR
PRESENTATION AND ANY WITNESSES --
HERE IN SUPPORT SO.
MISTER CHAIRMAN I APPRECIATE --
THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO THIS AT
THE LAST MINUTE LIKE THIS -- I'D
LIKE TO THANK -- CHAIRMAN GRAIN
TO STAFF PUTTING TOGETHER THIS
IMPORTANT HEARING ON SUCH SHORT
NOTICE.
WE ALL KNOW WHAT THIS BILL IS
ABOUT HERE TODAY THAT'S ABOUT
IMPORTANCE OF DOING THE RIGHT
THING I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I
BUT THANK YOU SENATOR AND YOU'RE
TAKING THE SUGGESTED COMMITTEE
MEHMET'S.
OKAY SO MEMBERS -- WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND -- THE
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
GRAY I BIGELOW.
AG WE ARE CURRY [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
BONSALL [inaudible]
WROTE [inaudible]
COOLEY [inaudible]
COOPER [inaudible]
DAILY [inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
GARCIA [inaudible]
GIBSON.
JOHN SAWYER HI.
LACKEY.
HELLO [inaudible]
MATH [inaudible]
MELINDA'S [inaudible]
WORK SILVA [inaudible]
REVERSE [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SOLID [inaudible]
SO -- RIGHT YES -- NINETEEN OKAY
CENTER WE HAVE -- NINETEEN VOTES
AND FOR THE RECORD LET'S TWENTY
BOATS -- FOR THE RECORD LET'S
CLARIFY THAT THE AMENDMENTS WERE
THE MOST RECENT VERSION
INCLUDING THE THE STATE MAKE
INSURING THAT THE BOARD HAS A
QUORUM.
PRESENT -- IN ORDER TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH THE MEETING.
ABSOLUTELY THAT'S IT.
TOTALLY UNDERSTOOD THAT'S RIGHT
WAY OF DOING IT THANK YOU SIR
APPRECIATE -- THE URGENCY THANK
YOU ALL